the fact that there are so many taxis in
Berlin is not only due to the German
capital's population of some
three-and-a-half million Berlin is also
popular with tourists and business
travelers and many of them use the 7600
taxi camps that ply the city streets
montine dole has been a cab driver for
more than 20 years at first it was just
a student job but now he's made a career
of driving his taxi to Berlin's 900
square kilometres disagrees to the size
of the city means that there are parts
of it that you might not visit for weeks
or even months it's not see father as a
cab driver I'm always surprised at how
much Berlin changes not the city's full
of construction sites and you may have
to contend with one for weeks and and
suddenly it's gone there's an apartment
house or a bridge or a shopping center
there or any broker or a shopping center
dole guides disoriented tourists through
the city make sure business travellers
catch their flights and sometimes has
some very special passengers
Lafayette Monument of course you have
celebrity passengers in Berlin I've
driven til Schweiger oder Lindenberg
nina hagen bay nina hot and buffeted
nights and witnessed and i drive for the
german parliament so of course I Drive a
lot of parliamentarians victims
sometimes you get a former minister
there have been taxi cabs in Berlin for
some 120 years and for decades they were
black in 1971 the color light ivory
became mandatory for taxis in West
Germany for years most of the cabs were
built by mercedes-benz but today like at
Berlin's main train station you see lots
of other models
Berlin's cab drivers have long been
considered a special breed
it helped a mechanism that's the initial
fudgie sign I always heard they weren't
supposed to be very friendly but so far
I found them all very nice mother knit
the kindest no sometimes you get a
loudmouth or someone who doesn't know
where the street is after all twice for
these carcinogens now they're fast did I
get you any one ago mister
taking a taxi in Berlin isn't terribly
expensive a 10 kilometer trip that takes
some 20 minutes costs around 20 euros
so a taxi father I've heard that there
are cab drivers who earn only 4 to 8
euros an hour that's not even the
minimum wage
he says 16 you go pack seaweed but as a
self-employed driver I work as long as I
need to
that can mean I ended up working 60
hours a week or more evoking me adding
what I'm after the Berlin Wall fell the
city's potsdamer platz which had been in
no-man's land was rebuilt from the
ground up it's a must-see for tourists
and everyone goes there vacationers
often ask dole if he can show them a
part of Berlin they won't necessarily
find in any Travel Guide so here's his
latest tip yeah I saw kissing tree I'm
parked like this is glice triac park
night it's Berlin's newest park and I
think it's one of the nicest it's ideal
for families with kids
here come on you can skate here go on
the swings shoku there's a water
playground and you're in the middle of
the city near potsdamer platz in der
stadt i'm puts them up nuts night time
in Berlin is when the workday really
starts for many taxi drivers for ten
years dole only drove at night these
days the Friedreich's hein Kreutz berg
district is the trendy part of town for
partying when dust decides of meat
machines the bleep this is the best view
at sunset whenever I Drive along here I
could drive here every day at sunset to
see this some sometimes I got none fun
club goers in Berlin are known for
making more than one party stop in the
course of a night out that's good
business for taxi drivers and some clubs
stay open through the entire weekend
Eclipse in belly insincere searle in
clubs are really hard to find because
they never have signs out front
you wonder why all these people are
lining up it turns out to be either a
popular snack bar or a club Knoxville
there's always something going on in
Berlin and that keeps taxi drivers busy
around the clock
you